this animation is brought to you by the
smart image base
a subscription website where you can
download thousands of medical images
and videos to use in lectures courses
presentations professional training and
more
for more information click on the link
in the description
x-ray images are like photos of the
inside of your body
but x-ray videos can be made as well
they're made during a procedure called
fluoroscopy
one reason your doctor may give you a
fluoroscopy exam is to find out if you
have certain diseases
such as problems in your digestive tract
a second reason your doctor may use
fluoroscopy is to perform a procedure
such as a spinal tap
a third reason is to find locate and
identify a foreign object
in your body there are several types of
fluoroscopy machines
a fluoroscope may be fixed in place in a
special shielded room
or it may be a portable machine that can
be moved to you if needed
a computed tomography or ct scan machine
can also be used as a fluoroscope to see
slices through the body
as the images are taken before a
fluoroscopy procedure
you may be given a contrast substance it
may be in
a drink a paste a pill
or an injection
during the procedure you will lie or
stand on an x-ray table
an x-ray tube will be aimed at the body
part to be examined
then an x-ray beam will pass through a
part of the fluoroscope that shapes the
beam
to just the area of your body being
studied
this helps reduce your exposure to
x-rays
after the beam passes through your body
it will be converted into a video seen
on a monitor screen
if you receive a contrast substance it
will make the structure stand out better
on the screen
if you have any questions about
fluoroscopy talk to your doctor